you can't say the same for joe biden joe
biden now now that the democrats have
tested out this court packing line he
himself has decided to adopt it
that following the constitution
and undermining the constitution are
actually the same thing only
court packing going on right now is
going on with republicans attacking the
court now
it's not constitutional what they're
doing we should be focused on what's
happening
right now and the fact is that the only
packing going on is
this court has been packed now by the
republicans
after the vote has already begun i'm
going to stay
focused on it so we don't take the eyes
off the ball here
what they're doing is not constitutional
what do you mean it's not constitutional
they this the constitution says the
presidential nominated judge and the
senate will advise and consent that's
exactly what they're doing
it's not that's not even an op it's not
like well you have this option
constitutionally there's a requirement
that the president nominate a judge
and the judge is going through but he's
just saying words right
that's not it's not constitutional it's
just like during the debate
when president trump said law
enforcement doesn't support biden he
goes that's not true man that's a lie
and and trump gave it okay name one
organization in law enforcement that
supports you
biden said uh uh he didn't have an
answer he just said he just goes it's
not constitutional
it's it's wrong it's come on man come on
man
so now he's saying we're we the
democrats
are going to add these judges to the
court now did you hear there was a cough
in there here he is yeah we met
there was a physical hacking up there
was a hacking up that happened and it
wasn't just
when he was talking about the judges he
was giving another campaign event in
nevada
and biden had his mask on he had the
mask on for some reason but it was below
his nose
so it was not doing any there was no
scientific or medical argument for the
way he was wearing the mask
but he had it on just as a just as a
political symbol because that's all it
is
the mask is the the political yard sign
of 2020.
the way joe biden is wearing that mask
offers absolutely no protection
against the virus either for himself or
for other people it's just there
as a symbol of his view of politics that
basically we should be led by
bureaucrats and experts
but then it gets even better because not
only is the mask down below his nose
but he has to cough so what does he do
when he has to cough
he pulls down the mask coughs into his
hand
he's there he pulls an investment right
into his right hand
then he puts the mask back up he
actually puts the mask up over his nose
after he coughs all over his hand he's
probably gonna go shake a lot of hands
after that
more evidence more evidence that the way
that this virus
is being treated is not primarily
focused on science
or medicine it's focused on politics
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you